يستمر كتاب قواعد السفر في تغيير
نيجيريا ، وقد تمت إضافته إلى القائمة الحمراء للمملكة المتحدة
والتي تصلها إلى ما مجموعه 10
دول في جنوب إفريقيا والتي يمكن فقط لمواطني المملكة المتحدة
السفر من الآن ، فأنت بحاجة إلى
الحجر الصحي في منشأة فندقية الآن إذا
كنت ستعود  من إحدى هذه
البلدان لمدة عشرة أيام وتكلفتها
حوالي ثلاثة آلاف دولار من
يوم غد ، هناك
متطلبات اختبار إضافية ، سيحتاج أي شخص يصل إلى المملكة المتحدة
لإجراء اختبار ما قبل المغادرة في
غضون يومين قبل الوصول 48
ساعة ، يمكن أن يكون اختبار مستضد أو اختبار
pcr وبغض النظر عن حالة التطعيم ،
فهذا أيضًا بالإضافة إلى الاضطرار إلى
إجراء اختبار في غضون يومين من وصوله
إلى المملكة المتحدة الآن ، حيث كان من الممكن أن
يكون اختبار مستضد سريعًا من قبل والذي يجب
أن يكون PCR والذي بالطبع لا
يثير هؤلاء  وهذا هو سبب وجود
مخاوف من أنه قد يمنع بعض الأشخاص
من السفر وقطاع السفر
والسياحة ليس سعيدًا ، فهناك
دعوات لحكومة المملكة المتحدة
لمنحهم المزيد من المال.  الدعم المالي نظرًا لهذه
القيود الجديدة إما في شكل
مخطط الإجازة العائد للقطاع
أو الدعم المالي الإضافي أو حتى
دفع تكاليف الاختبارات
الإلزامية أثناء هذا الوباء ،
فمن الممكن تمامًا ، إنه
مجرد تكاليف الاختبارات التي يجب أخذها
في الاعتبار  يجب أن تكون منظمًا
لحجزهم جميعًا مسبقًا
وبالطبع يجب أن تكون مرنًا نظرًا لأن
القواعد يمكن أن تتغير من مكانك وأين
تحاول الوصول إلى Anna Stewart cnn
london